في الاستوديو نورنا الاستشاري نفسي دكتور
نادر ياغي دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا
بصباح العربيه بالفعل هناك اختلاف بين
العمر البيولوجي والعمر الحقيقي للانسان
طبعا في اختلاف كبير احنا اللي بنشوف احنا
دائما بنقولها احنا بنشوف عمرنا اللي
مكتوب في الشهاده اللي مكتوب في الاي دي
بس احنا اللي بنشوفه احنا واحنا بنتعامل
مع الناس هذا عمر واحنا قاعدين لحالنا هذا
عمر احنا دائما بنعتبر احنا الانسان عنده
ثلاث انواع او ثلاث ارقام من العمر العمر
الحقيقي اللي مكتوب والعمر اللي بتعامل
فيه مع الناس والعمر اللي بيني وبين نفسي
وهذا اللي بيكون كارثه
على حسب المتنشن عندي مشكله في الشغل عندي
مشكله مع الزوج عندي مشكله مع اي حدا مع
الناس ببدا انا لما بروح البيت بشوف نفسي
اني انا صار عمري فوق 100 سنه لاني كان
لازم اعمل كذا لازم اعمل كذا هذه النقطه
المهمه الناس اللي بتقعد تسال طب ايش
التاثير انا اسف اني اني دخلت في سؤال
يمكن كنتوا حابين تسالوه اللي هو نحن
بنقوله دائما ايش التاثير النفسي على
الشخص التاثير النفسي اللي بيخلي عمر كبير
يعني بنشوف انه ممكن انا انا انا قلتها
ممكن اكون عمري خمسين ولكن ما عنديش
تجاعيد اكثر او ما عنديش كذا اكثر او ما
عنديش التكشيره ما عنديش ال 111 ما عنديش
اشياء لاني بالليل هذه النقطه مهمه اللي
بنشوفها مع ناس المساكين بالليل طول الوقت
اه انا صار عندي الان 45 طب انا شو جبت في
حياتي طب انا شو عندي فلوس طيب انا ما
تزوجتش طب لا انا عندي اولاد طيب انا
اولادي لسه ما تخرجوش هذه المشكله اللي
بتخليني بصحى الصبح انا ما صار انا لو انا
نايم وانا عمري 45 الصبح انا عمري 55 هذه
اللي بتخلينا احنا نفكر في الدنيا بعمر مش
عمرنا الحقيقي نعم كيف الانسان دائما حتى
بكل شيء يصب بمساله التفكير والتفكير طب
دكتور نادر اليوم اذا في شخص
كبير في السن او امراه
يتصرفوا كانهم اصغر 30 سنه يعني بالعاميه
نقول متصابه او متصابيه هل هؤلاء يعانون
من ازمه نفسيه بحكم انك استشاري نفسي ولا
لا انه هذا هو الصح انه هو هذا الصح
بالنسبه 80% عشان نكون واقعيين بنسبه 80
في الميه العشرين في الميه اللي ما حتكون
صح لما انا بتصابه باذيكي سوري انا جاي
مثلا هانوب وبعمل حركات
تميصت وعملت نفسي شويه مراهق حتى دايق مش
ما الها معنى هواء او مش تحت هواء فهمت
كيف حتى ممكن تشك انه من كثر المياصه ان
هو ما له علاقه بالذكوره هذا اللي بتكلم
عليه اللي هي اتصابى لمرحله اني حاسس
الطرف الاخر اني في اذيه للمشاعر في انه
هو ممكن يحكم علي بطريقه مختلفه لكن الان
انا ممكن اني مثلا في العمر تبعي صرت اغير
الملابس صرت البس الوان فاتحه اكثر
انا ما شفت الاجابه هاي بس انا هقولها لك
بمنتهى البساطه بدون فلسفه هي بتعمل حاجه
حلوه جدا
انت بتعملي حاجه اسمها في علم النفس انك
تعيشي اللحظه تبعتها
اي بني ادم عاوز يكون ناجح في حياته يكون
مارح يكون كويس يكون طيب يكون حكيم تعيشي
اللحظه زي ما انتم كنتم بتحكي معي تحت
الهوا فبتقولي لي طب احنا مثلا انا مش
عارف ايش لما بكون مبسوطه بتلاقيني كذا
لما بعصب يكون شكلي كذا ايه اللي انت
بتعمليه هذا جيد جدا انت بتعيشي اللحظه
قاعده في الملاهي عيش اللحظه تبعتك هتعيشي
مع احترامي طبعا انت مذيعه ومشهوره وكذا
اه حدا يطلع اذا فكرت في هيك كل عام وانت
بخير اقعدي في البيت ما تطلعي من البيت
ضلك من التلفزيون لهاي عيش اللحظه اجمل
حياه واللحظات الانسان لما بعيش اللحظه
تبعته وكل الاشخاص اللي بعان من ازمات
نفسيه واكثر لما يوصل لازمه منتصف العمر
هم اللي ما عاشوا شبابهم وطفولتهم بالعمر
الحقيقي
ولحظات السعاده والفرح وكل هذه الامور هاي
للاسف انا بكون قاعد مع اشخاص وفي عندي
شخص مثلا بعرفه عزيز علي لما بنيجي نتناقش
انا واحد اصدقائنا مثلا انا دايما بقول
عصر الجاهليه ايام ما كنا في المراهقه
وكذا والمغامرات هذه الاشياء فهو دايما
بيقعد معنا بيعمل بعيني هيك ينبهر وهذا
حبيبي انت ما عشته الان اللي انت بتسمعه
بالفعل والله انه صدق لما احنا بنكون احنا
الثلاثه جالسين هو يبان اكبر منا عمرك مع
العلم اني انا اكبر منه عمرا يمكن باكثر
من ست سنوات قلت له ما هو هذا انت شايل
الهم احنا بنقولها باللهجات العاميه باي
لهجه بالعاميه العربيه او في اي موطن
بيقول لك شال الهم بدري ما تزعلوا مني
احنا في الوطن العربي يعني الهم موجود جاي
جاي الحمد لله بتوزع بالكيلو عندنا فعيش
اللحظه لما بتلاقي في عندك لحظه حلوه عيشه
هتلاقي نفسك حياتك هيصغر العمر تبعك هيبان
انك انت اصغر من العمر الافتراضي اللي هو
مسجل في الرقم القومي تبعك شكرا جزيلا
دكتور نادر نفسي نورتنا شكرا